president biden has warned russian
leader vladimir putin to stop
cyber criminals operating in russia who
are targeting u.s
companies in a phone call on friday mr
biden said the united states was
prepared to take quote
any action necessary to defend u.s
infrastructure
following last weekend's largest
ransomware attack to date
christina ruffini is at the white house
with the latest good morning christina
good morning michelle the white house is
trying to put pressure on russia
to stop these groups from operating what
are essentially cyber hit squads from
within its territory
but as these attacks seem to be getting
more frequent and more damaging
experts point out they're just the ones
we know about
you said three weeks ago there would be
consequences will there be sir
yes president biden didn't clarify
exactly what action the u.s will take
in response to another major cyber
attack against american companies by
groups based in russia
but says he did make a few things clear
to russian president vladimir putin
[Applause]
the two men spoke by phone on friday as
law enforcement agencies try to track
down the perpetrators of a sophisticated
attack on a software management company
that took up to 1500 companies offline
over the fourth of july weekend
this comes after a ransomware attack in
may forced the shutdown of the colonial
oil and gas pipeline
causing shortages up and down the east
coast another area we spent a great deal
of time on
was cyber and cyber security
russian-based hackers were a key topic
of conversation when the two leaders met
last month in geneva
responsible countries need to take
action against criminals
who conduct ransomware activities on
their territory
although experts do not believe these
hacks are being carried out by the
russian government
the russian government is doing very
little if anything
to stop them they're acting with
impunity but not the directs
not at the direction of the russian
government that's correct the u.s
government trying to put pressure on
the russians to say regardless of
whatever the arrangement
is we need this to stop rob lee is ceo
of dragos an industrial cyber security
firm
but until there's some actual
consequence it
benefits if anything uh the russians to
see consequence getting laid against you
know the us and others with no blowback
effect whatsoever for themselves
now the keystroke battle isn't just
going on with hackers there's also a bit
of one between the kremlin and the white
house
yesterday the kremlin released a
different statement summarizing the call
between the two leaders
and said washington has not asked moscow
to take any specific action
regarding these hacks a senior
administration official we talked to
said the u.s has conveyed
multiple specific requests to russia
they've been very clear about what they
believe russia's specific responsibility
on this issue is
and ended with they would just leave it
at that michelle
dan i'm sorry that's okay christina
thank you very much